well getting the start tonight here for
the tampa bay rays is going to be
right-hander yoni torinos his work from
a season ago
of course you know he gets to do a
little bit of everything he had 18
traditional starts also worked eight
times out of the bullpen overall good
numbers nine and five three point eight
five on the earned run average that'll
bring up ozzie albies
this one's golfed into right field past
lau and ozzy albees has the first hit
for atlanta he'll slam on the brakes and
that'll break up the no hitter atlanta's
got a runner board in front of tonight's
designated hitter freddie freeman
full count one out
and the pitch call to strike the throw
to second is also a strike a strike him
out throw him out double play
ends the braves top of the first inning
michael perez with a strike good lineup
but 21 starts at gwynette last season
11-4 record 417 era lots of strikeouts
and his last 10 were spectacular first
pitch is caught on a missed he attacked
choi and retired him on three pitches
excellent start for kyle wright
one up one down who's getting their
first look at him jose martinez
0-2 pitch fastball in on the hands hit
on the ground up the third base side
fielded by camargo long throw across and
that pulls adams off the bag and the
throw actually goes off a screen
protecting the stands no matter how you
score it hinders aboard let's see if he
thinks about doing some running as alex
jackson comes up still searching for
that first big league hit alex wants to
join the party there's a shot and there
it is a base hit into the left field
corner ender flying around second on his
way to third titsugo got to it quickly
and there it is the first major league
hit for alex jackson on no doubt about
it double into the left field corner way
to go kid had a kid
tough tough hitter though freddie
freeman standing in for the runners
leading at every base
and a cut in the mist and boy he made
some dandy pitches right there to get
the tough hitter freeman so a couple of
strikeouts back to back
two outs now bases still loaded
back-to-back strikeouts ozuna waits in
the right-hand batter's box base is
loaded two down
smacked into left field at base hit one
run scores here comes jackson to third
they'll throw up a stop sign for him and
ozuna comes through with a huge two out
hit and the braves have broken through
it's one to nothing so the bases are
loaded and yoshi satsugo is going to be
the hitter
lighter into right field that's in there
for a base set
myers scores loud's going to head to the
plate he will score and the rays take
the lead cashing in on the opportunity
tosugo driving in a pair 2-1 raise so
they're at the corners still two men out
and here's the dh jose martinez
right-handed batter
and a fly ball
short left ozuna coming in a hurry it's
going to drop he's hit run scores and
the rays make it a three to one game she
won two out eighth man to ban the
innings joey wendell has the best
contact of the night so far against
wright with a deep fly out to left
center one into the count to wendell and
the pitch is grounded sharply back to
the middle base head turns right center
field around third is tatsugo he will
score easily in martinez to third base
rounds it and then holds on rbi single
joey wendell and the rays quite the
answer four two out runs and they lead
at four to one and now with runners at
the corners and two outs the ninth man
to come to the plate this inning is
hunter renfrow here's a wild pitch that
goes to the backstop racing for the
players martinez and he'll score
standing up wendell goes to second it's
5-1 raise
wild pitch for tomlin that is a rarity
ozzy timmons going to work and no seeds
this year so just uh
harassing him with a towel it looks like
let's get creative
yes you do ozzy batting left against the
right-hander camargo at third base acuna
at first base
two men out braves down four
elevated fastball and ozzie rifles it to
right field for a base here that'll
score camargo and the braves are on the
board again here in the seventh inning
it's five to two so here's the spot for
freddy freeman freddy's got the hat
trick tonight three strikeouts
that'll do it swing gonna miss
freeman out on strikes for the fourth
time tonight
19 strikeouts last night for ray's
pitching they have 11 tonight
so 30 strikeouts in the
first two games here against atlanta
ground ball off the mound and a nice hop
there for wendell and the throw to
brasso in time
for the first out rings are down to
their 27th and final out trailing five
to two in the ninth
high fly ball
short right on the right side lao
just to step into the outfield makes the
catch
and that will win it
one two three in the ninth inning the
rays come away with a 5-2 victory here
tonight